if Plato were to come back today I think
he would have a lot to say about so many
things but but crowdsourcing would be of
great interest to him
I take Plato to the Googleplex and he's
very very interested in our technology
and that that would appeal to him very
much
but he gets into a conversation at the
Googleplex with a software engineer on
crowdsourcing and could crowdsourcing
answer the kind of ethical questions
that he first raised and he is he's
quite interested in this idea but he's
very he's very down he's very much
against it because you know he doesn't
he didn't have much faith in the ethical
opinions of the masses he thought that
ethics was a kind of knowledge that is
extremely hard to attain he's right I
mean that's one of the reasons we've
left him so far behind it's slowly
slowly where we make progress ethical
ethical progress but he thought you know
was a kind of knowledge and it takes a
trained mind and you know it's harder
than mathematics mathematics is a
preparation for this kind of knowledge
that you need that kind of dispassion
and distance and from your own life to
be able to access ethical knowledge so
he would not have been very interested
in crowdsourcing and what is the opinion
of the masses of people and he also
would say I think well then how do we
ever make any ethical progress how do we
ever learn anything new to to challenge
our intuitions if in fact it's just
being crowd-sourced I do have Plato
getting quite addicted to the Internet
looking up things on on the channel
Wikipedia constantly I mean that was
partly I I needed a quick way to bring
him up to speed and and he is constant
so he carries he gets well he's at the
Googleplex he gets a Chromebook they
give him a Chromebook and he he carries
it with him everywhere I'm he's
constantly consulting it but again he is
he believed in in the expert he believed
you know in expertise he Aristotle his
student was actually says some things
that are much more consonant or
favorable toward crowdsourcing you know
he says that you know if you go to a a
meal if it's just cooked by one person
you may not like it but if it's a feast
with many many people bringing their
dishes you'll find something to like
Aristotle says and he he really has an
idea there of crowdsourcing let's let's
try to get as many points of view as
possible Plato is is very dubious of
this he he believes that it's extremely
difficult to know anything it takes a
tremendous amount of training years and
years of training he has the rulers of
his state studying advanced mathematics
for ten years before they can even think
about political philosophy that's how
hard he thinks these things are
you